es hora que empecemos a innovar en donde
nadie está innovando todavía en sistema
político
porque nuestra democracia está
terriblemente estancada y ya no es capaz
de responder a las demandas de una
sociedad que se complejiza cada vez más
y se transforma de la mano de las nuevas
tecnologías
y trabajar en política no es fácil yo he
hecho empecé mi vida en el mundo de la
sociedad civil
pero yo creo que necesitamos distribuir
mejor el poder compartir el conocimiento
y encontrar espacios de diálogo que nos
permitan llegar a mejores soluciones con
más consenso
y la política es la mejor herramienta
que tenemos para hacerlo
entonces hace un par de años decidí dar
el salto de fe y empecé a trabajar en
una campaña electoral en la provincia de
buenos aires
y lo que vi vamos nada de nada
primero nadie discutía ideas de lo único
que se discutía era de personas no me
acuerdo una vuelta como veía como le
borraba en los bigotes y le blanqueaban
los dientes con photoshop a un candidato
pues tenía que parecer joven no
importaba que sus ideas fueran del siglo
pasado lo único que importaba era
aparentar
una vuelta me encontré en un galpón
municipal en el conurbano de la
provincia de buenos aires- tenían stock
ya destacadas chapas colchones
materiales de construcción sin repartir
cuando yo pregunto que hacía todo eso
ahí porque no lo repartían me contestan
con una frescura terrible no te das
cuenta lo estamos jugando el año que
viene para las elecciones clara diseño
no había elecciones
la gente no votaba que importaba que no
tuviera techo o no tuviera un lugar
donde dormir si total ese año no se le
consultaba y ese es el problema nosotros
vivimos en un sistema político que
responde una tecnología de la
información de hace 400 años de la
imprenta
cuando los que eran considerados
ciudadanos
ya no podían participar de los espacios
en donde se tomaban las decisiones y
tampoco tenían el acceso a la
información necesaria para tomarlas
entonces lo que se diseñó un sistema
basado en intermediarios
los representantes son intermediarios
entre los ciudadanos y aquellos espacios
no se toman las decisiones que
impactaban en su vida
y es la misma democracia que tenemos hoy
en día
pero la sociedad cambio
miren esta es la asunción del papá en el
y la misma foto en 2013
si queremos enterarnos de cualquier tema
no tenemos más que meternos en wikipedia
o incluso podemos buscar alguna terna al
respecto
quien no se enteró primero por un
usuario de twitter sobre algún suceso en
cualquier lugar del mundo antes que por
un medio tradicional de comunicación
quien no post yo alguna vez obvio ha
posteado estoy buscando un colaborador
este es mi currículum necesito un
departamento para alquilar
hoy es más probable
que encontremos trabajo a través de
linkedin y a través de una agencia y un
departamento a través de facebook que
traes una inmobiliaria
y ni que hablar de como la conectividad
transformó la industria de la cultura y
el entretenimiento
está cambiando incluso nuestra
percepción sobre la propiedad hoy
queremos tener el cde físico
o lo que queremos es escuchar la música
queremos tener el dvd y archivado en la
biblioteca o lo que queremos es poder
ver la película
internet lo que hace es que baja
radicalmente las barreras de acceso a la
información y nos transforma a todos
nosotros en productores consumidores de
información internet nos permite
estructurar nos depara para sin
intermediarios y todos podemos
participar virtualmente de la gran
conversación global
internet transformó esa conversación que
era de pocos a muchos a una conversación
de muchos a muchos la democratizó y esto
lo estamos viendo en todos los ámbitos
en la cultura en la educación en la
organización del trabajo en lo social
incluso en la economía
pero la política
el sistema político insiste en excluir
nos de los espacios en donde se toman
las decisiones
y la consecuencia
en todo el mundo
es esta
es un choque entre un sistema que ya no
representa
y no tiene capacidad de diálogo
y un montón de ciudadanos que estamos
cada vez más acostumbrados a
representarnos a nosotros mismos sin
intermediarios
miren 'occupy wall street' los
indignados españoles los estudiantes
chilenos la primavera árabe
son todos ejemplos de esta crisis global
de representación
yo veía todo este vapor que la válvula
el sistema político que tenemos ya no
contiene la pregunta que no podía evitar
hacer mes como vamos a hacer para pasar
de la agitación a la construcción
porque parece que podemos usar las redes
sociales para un costo muy bajo
organizarnos para grandes movilizaciones
masivas
pero lo que no discutimos es que
queremos hacer después
que instituciones queremos construir
para esta nueva sociedad de enredo
entonces si internet en la nueva
imprenta
la pregunta que nos tenemos que estar
haciendo es esta
cuál es la democracia de la era de
internet
entonces con un grupo de personas
armamos acá en argentina una fundación
que se llama democracia en red
y tiene como objetivo pensar cómo
podemos hacer para transformar todo este
ruido en señal que tenga llegada directa
al sistema
y empezamos a ver un montón de ejemplos
en todo el mundo
y decidimos crear una instancia nueva de
participación ciudadana y de pensamiento
social para las legislaturas locales la
pregunta que nos motivaba es cómo
podíamos aprovechar esta nueva
tecnología que estábamos viendo para
hacer que nuestros representantes
representan
hay dos razones por las cuales elegimos
este camino
la primera es porque nosotros creemos
que los costos para la participación son
demasiado altos si participar en
política significa militar todos los
días desde la universidad para alguna
vez tal vez sentarse en alguna mesa de
algún partido que tome alguna decisión
si participar en política significa
poner una mesa en una esquina salir a
juntar 4.000 firmas y armar un proyecto
de ley para después esperar que nuestros
legisladores le presten atención
si participar en política significa
tener que ser abogado para entender de
qué se tratan las leyes que están
regulando nuestra vida entonces
claramente van a ser los menos los que
van a querer participar pero qué pasa si
se le hacemos más fácil a ciudadanos
qué pasa si podemos crear un espacio en
donde incluso aquellos que solamente
tienen una hora por semana pero les
importan los temas de su ciudad y tienen
algo para decir lo puedan hacer
la segunda razón por la cual elegimos
este camino es porque nosotros creemos
que llegamos a mejores decisiones
escuchando la mayor cantidad de voces
posibles
entonces porque pensamos que un
legislador decidiendo sólo va a poder
comprender mejor todas las aristas que
significan diseñar un proyecto de ley e
implementar lo que sí lo hace en
conjunto con aquellos que son
directamente afectados por esa por esa
ley
ahora como hacemos para meter 100.000
ideas en una banca
como hacemos para que un legislador
encarne todas esas posturas diferentes
bueno de vuelta aprovechemos la
tecnología y exploremos ese camino
y entonces el sistema que diseñamos es
un sistema que tiene dos componentes se
llama democracia o es un componente
online y un componente offline el
componente online es una red social para
la participación democrática es una
plataforma web que nos va a permitir
informarnos debatir y votar como
queremos que voten nuestros legisladores
informarnos es clave les voy a leer
ahora
una ley no es un proyecto es una ley
desafecte sea del distrito de
zonificación urbanización futura efe del
código de planeamiento urbano las
fracciones de la manzana 75 la sección
92 circunscripción una y afecte sea
distrito hurón insecto
me entiendan no es chiste esto es así
esto quiere decir que van a cambiar la
zonificación de
a dos manzanas para que ahí se pueden
hacer torres bueno cambia la cosa si
nosotros supiéramos que la esquina de
casa van a hacer una torre no tendríamos
algo para decir no sé por ahí por ahí
estamos de acuerdo o por ahí no pero si
no nos informamos si no nos enteramos
nunca vamos a poder opinar entonces lo
primero que vamos a hacer es listar
todos los proyectos de ley que están hoy
en discusión y los vamos a explicar para
que todos los podamos entender
y ahora una vez que nos enteramos que
nos informamos si tenemos una opinión
qué pasa hoy con todas estas opiniones
mueren en una charla de café o hacen su
camino a los comentarios de un diario
online
pero qué pasa si nosotros podemos crear
un espacio que estructura todas esas
opiniones que en donde se debatan donde
esas ideas terminen en proyectos de ley
que realmente representen a nuestra
comunidad en donde si uno está cómodo
con un determinado tema pueda votar pero
si no está como pueda delegar ese voto
en otra persona en la cual confía pero
para ese tema en particular no ya por
dos años enteros nos interesaría
participar de un espacio así
hoy qué opciones nos da el sistema para
participar
una audiencia pública martes a las 11 de
la mañana en pleno microcentro quienes
de acá pueden estar a las 11 de la
mañana en el microcentro en martes para
poder emitir una opinión porque tenemos
que seguir participando físicamente de
estos espacios y esa es nuestra única
alternativa
nosotros hoy podemos estudiar en un
curso a distancia de una universidad que
nunca vamos a ver en la vida podemos
intentar financiarnos con micro
donaciones de gente de todo el mundo
trabajamos en red con gente que
probablemente nunca vayamos a conocer
pero no le podemos decir a nuestro
legislador
si queremos enrejar o no la plaza de la
esquina de casa
bueno no parece tener mucho sentido y
acá es donde entra este componente
offline que es fundamental que son los
partidos políticos y porque es
fundamental porque en argentina el
monopolio de la representación no tienen
los partidos políticos la única manera
que nosotros tenemos de llevar esta
inteligencia colectiva y que tenga
impacto directo en el sistema es a
través de partidos políticos que se
presenten a elecciones que ganen bancas
y que se comprometan a votar de acuerdo
a lo que se decía en esta plataforma
imagínense a un legislador que va a las
reuniones de comisión y la firma para
que todos los podamos ver
imagínense ese legislador que discute
en un foro online los domingos con todos
los ciudadanos no es imposible nos
mandaron una misión a la luna las
herramientas están entonces la
plataforma que nosotros creamos es de
código abierto y libre porque lo que
necesitamos son partidos políticos que
se animen a cambiar la lógica a través
de la cual toman las decisiones que
dejen de hacerlo de espaldas a la
ciudadanía y lo empiecen a lo empiecen a
hacer con aquellos a quienes están
afectando directamente por esas
decisiones que somos todos nosotros
imagínense todo lo que podemos hacer si
nosotros nos animamos innovar donde
nadie no va todavía en el sistema
político todo lo que podemos lograr
marshall mcluhan dicen que la política
es resolver los problemas de hoy con las
herramientas de hallar bueno es hora que
resolvamos los problemas de hoy con las
herramientas de hoy muchas gracias